[Music]
[Music]
coming I don't think you've come to see
me
you've come to hear about the title this
is the first time I've given this talk
sign a bit nervous and I'll be very
grateful for your criticisms you can be
blunt you can't frighten me with your
critic will be very helpful
it's brace on a book that I'm writing
called why can't a woman be more like a
man which will be published Nixon a
little extreme however the title I
really wanted why isn't a man more like
a woman and you will see why I come to
that in a moment
because one of the things I'm going to
say is that men are basically modified
women but we'll come to that all in the
moment and so what it's really about is
to try and understand I am a I'm a
biologist and I wanted to understand the
biological differences between men and
women and how much the differences
between men and women were determined by
biology as distinct from social
resisting from from so social factors
how different are our brains what role
is evolution played and just do remember
you are nothing more than a society of
cells ok
you do know you do say that every night
before you go to sleep I you are a
society of cells and that determines
everything and the way cells function is
largely by determined what proteins 0
genes are boring but they provide the
code Gene's do nothing they just sit
there totally passive but they provide
the code for making proteins and
proteins determine how cells work it's
not it's largely proteins and it's quite
interesting in an interview to mark his
70th birthday Stephen Hawking the famous
physicist admitted that he spent most of
the day thinking about women you know
what he said they are he said a complete
mystery
now if I look back in history the
striking thing about men and women is
that men have discriminated against
women and what for as far back as you
want to go you know there has been no
time when men have not discriminated
against women they were given the prime
end up responding women were there to
look after the home and to look after
the children and has been subordinate
and if you just look back at one of the
stores I'm not going to take you through
there's details think of the legend of
Pandora do you remember the legend of
Pandora let me remind you and that of
Eve Pandora was the Greek one and she
had taken she's given this very sacred
bottle and she lived things slip out and
evil therefore came up to the world for
the first time and I don't have to
remind you what even so in two
completely different cultures Greek and
Christianity the women of the cause of
all evil I forgive you I don't think
it's true now I think you have to
realize that a crucial thing is we're
talking about men and women is it how
you develop really matters and as I told
you I am a developmental biologist said
this matters a great a great deal to me
and as Mark Twain said what would men be
without women scarce mighty scarce the
best thing about my talk of my funny
quotations
now the early development of the embryo
is identical for men and women okay I
see someone's nodding he knows okay
the sexual differences begin to develop
later and it's really because if there's
a y-chromosome that comes from the man
that causes the embryo to develop testes
and testes caused the result in the
secretion of testosterone and therefore
that modifies the developing embryo to
develop as a male because what the y
chromosome is the male chromosome so all
you ladies have XX chromosomes repour
males and X and Y and the Y chromosome
makes the embryo masculine by causing a
testers to develop there are other genes
too I'm not going to take is too but the
main thing is that it leads the testers
leads to the secretion of testosterone
which modifies the embryo to develop as
a male so in that sense males are
modified females because this test the Y
chromosome has modified female
development to develop into a male I
hope that's clear and you can ask why do
males have breasts and nipples we don't
feed many babies I have to say and
they're not terribly sensitive or
attractive and the reason is they
developed in females and that since
males or modified females they were just
left there when the embryo developed it
didn't have any influence on them
whatsoever and just let me remind you
that testosterone you know the male
hormone is crucial and there is an a
genetic illness called CAH congenital
adrenal hyperplasia which results in
there being more testosterone in
than normal and I'll come back to the
impact of that because we can see what
effect it has but first of all let's
have a quick look at evolution now on
the whole if you look at the literature
on the subject most there are many books
is about about the differences between
men and women evolution is not something
that most of them even touch on but it's
very important first of all it's just
we're thinking why bother to have two
sexes wouldn't it would be less fun to
have just one but what because I'm not
gonna take you through it's quite
complicated biological problem but it's
a way of generating more variety and
evolution cares about variety and just
let me tell you evolution only cares
about reproduction it doesn't give a
damn about anything else it's only cares
how reproductive you are I don't want to
take you through and that's why when you
get old evolution says bye-bye Dolly
gray you've reproduced I don't give a
damn about you anymore now what
evolution did make sure is that both
sexes wanted to get needed to get
pleasure from sex because that's what
reproduction is about and care of young
children also has to be genetically
determined particularly in the mothers
and this has a great influence yes maybe
it's a little jetan ethically determined
in the father's but if I look at you I
think about yes the fathers can be but
nothing compared to the thing and the
other things it's just worth remembering
from evolution
you must not mate with relatives
brothers must not mate with sisters you
must not mate with the first cousin
genetically it's disastrous
there's incest and this is also
genetically determined for both bin and
women not to mate with him and Charles
Darwin had I'm afraid to tell you rather
negative views of women man is more
courageous pugnacious energetic than
women and has a more inventive genius
women seems to differ from man and
mental disposition
chiefly in their great attendances
unless selfishness and I think he's
probably bloody will write on the second
on the second one they ordered and I've
come back to the tenderness in a moment
so there was mating behavior
historically and it was probably the
most vigorous and strongest males who
had access to women had the easiest
access of women and in general it is
that men more than women have ever
greater desire for casual sex I don't
think I have to press I don't think I
have to persuade you on that school um
your women are more really concerned
about relationships but men will do
almost anything for six alright man if
there's a nice relationship to how very
nice now in ancient societies the
supplies of food were largely provided
by women while the wind men went art you
know protecting and hunting for big food
it's the women who developed agriculture
it is very important to do they made
major technical contributions women's
food gathering activity led to animal
demonstrate domestication and
agriculture you women discovered
agriculture I have to tell you you also
discovered cooking and you also evolved
in making pots all that was done by
women and when you're agriculture became
better the men stopped going out hunting
and came home and took over all your
inventions and took them from themselves
I'm terribly sorry that's the way things
winds but just remember they then became
because they're their physical strengths
became or dominance
[Music]